the public suggests that prime minister  clegg  no  mister who said probably minister clegg  for a moment the public suggests they  can't forgive that one thing so if  hindsight would you go into coalition in  2010  yes absolutely i i in fact the more i  look back on it the more  proud i am that though i think it was a  difficult decision i think it was a  brave decision for uh for the liberal  democrats it's come at short-term  political cost but i'm absolutely clear  in my mind that if you think back to  2010 we could have been greece  we could have been greece our deficit  was almost as big as greece's our  banking crisis was a whole lot worse and  i certainly wouldn't have wanted on my  conscience higher interest rates higher  unemployment higher youth unemployment  which i'm absolutely sure would have  happened if we hadn't stepped up to the  plate to create a stable government  without which an economic recovery is  not possible in my